all right we're live gonna be doing
reaction to what happened just now with
Donald Trump's first address to Congress
joint session of Congress not called the
State of the Union just called a
presidential address since Donald Trump
has only been president for about 38
days or so I'm gonna wait for people to
connect we are gonna get started in a
second I'll be giving you my general
impressions gonna go through policy
ideas going to talk about the claims the
accomplishment claims that Donald Trump
made and much much more so we're gonna
have a lot a lot a lot to talk about as
I wait for people to connect by all
means feel free to say hello in the
comments say hello in the chat but it's
gonna be really a lot to talk about
super chat is on I'll be doing live
shoutouts and thank-yous to new members
at david pakman.com slash membership
just truly so much to discuss after this
first address congressional address by
President Donald Trump wear my glasses
not wearing my contacts as people
clearly seem to be noticing noticing I'm
gonna start in a second just waiting for
for more people to connect by the way I
saw I see already in the chat a couple
of people saying hey David did you ever
post the picture of the tuna you were
going to see her when you signed off on
the last live stream I did it's on my
Instagram account at David Pakman I
think someone just called it haddock but
no it was it was tuna please follow me
on instagram by the way David Pakman
okay let's get into it so let me do my
miscellaneous sort of observations first
and then I'll talk to you about policy
ideas that Donald Trump presented and
then I will talk to you about the
accomplishments that he took credit for
okay feel free to send super chats of
course definitely feel free to sign up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership the coupon code
I voted 17 is still going and I will get
to live thank-yous and shout outs for
sure okay so first of all opening right
'we black history anti-semitism this was
a signal to me that this was going to be
a heavily pandering speech from donald
trump and indeed it was okay when Donald
Trump is trying to give an applause line
you absolutely should applaud because
otherwise he's not going to continue
that was something that became clear
right away obviously very strange
reading very labored awkward so on and
so forth
no surprise there the set up for the
entire thing was utterly and completely
farcical in the sense that he talked
about this bad situation that he
inherited from former President Barack
Obama and just about everything he said
there was a lie talking about how the
economy was just absolutely terrible
worst financial recovery actually
unemployment is almost at what
economists would call full employment
the stock market more than doubling
under President Obama going on to the
labor force talk 93 million people not
in the labor force we've already talked
about why that doesn't really tell us
what we need to know about the economy
I'm not gonna rehash at all now
maybe tomorrow on the show it's after
it's 10:15 here on the East Coast so
we'll dig into that but totally farcical
talking about losing manufacturing jobs
since NAFTA approval first of all NAFTA
was approved in 1993 so if it's a way to
if he's trying to blame Obama it depends
on people not realizing that he that
they don't know that NAFTA was actually
signed in 1993 and of course the reason
we're losing a lot of these
manufacturing jobs is that these jobs
are disappearing not only are they going
to other countries in part because of
people like Donald Trump sending them to
other countries but because technology
is destroying those jobs as I watched
the Republicans clapping I wondered how
many of these Republicans really just
think that Trump is a lunatic who's
completely clueless and are just playing
along until those approval drops into
the 20s and then I also found
interesting that Donald
chompin talking about his proposal to
repeal and replace Obamacare which I'll
dig into more he talked about what we
want to give States the flexibility with
Medicaid to prevent people from being
left out that's exactly what the
Affordable Care Act known
interchangeably as Obamacare did with
regard to something called the Medicaid
expansion that was federally subsidized
at one point Trump pointing to a black
social worker that was his invited
guests or something he talked about
wanting to get her a great job Trump
wants to cut the types of funding that
would prevent many of the jobs that she
could potentially be doing from having
the money to exist so everything about
this was just a complete hypocrisy
contradiction what do you guys think
we'll see at 3:00 a.m. tonight from from
Trump on his Twitter account my speech
was big ly tremendous at least half the
room clapped every time I said something
so clearly I did well and then the most
horrible horrible moment for me from the
entire thing really the cringe-worthy
moment was when Donald Trump started
pandering to the widow of Ryan Owens the
Navy SEAL who tragically died in this
completely botched raid in Yemen which
Donald Trump couldn't even be bothered
to be in the Situation Room for which
Donald Trump approved over a casual
dinner with his advisers I mean truly
disgusting and bringing in his widow
Karen Owens and it was some of the worst
and most disgusting political pandering
that I've seen Trump touted the
intelligence that was obtained recently
Sean Spicer said it's unbelievable how
much intelligence we got from there yes
it's AI nobody should believe it because
it appears that it was absolutely and
totally bogus
and painful to watch not only because of
the visible agony of Karen Owens but
also because of just the cringe-worthy
absolutely cringe-worthy pandering that
took place and for people who were
saying David all those people it wasn't
pandering they all chose to be there
yeah they chose to be there I mean
when you get a call that the White House
is requesting your presence yeah some
people will turn that down but most
people will not and it was absolutely
horrible and also that doesn't tell us
anything about the facts of whether it's
absolutely disgusting pandering or not
okay so those are my sort of impressions
generally next I'm going to get into
policy ideas and next I'm going to get
into accomplishments that Trump took
credit for okay so there's a lot to
discuss here I want to send a big thank
you to Patrick cheek Patrick cheek just
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership membership is the number one
funding source for the show nearly three
hundred and thirty thousand YouTube
subscribers strong and we will continue
to grow and do more programming for you
in proportion to the support that we get
if the normal membership rates strike
you is high by all means use our we have
this coupon code I voted seventeen saves
you forty percent okay you get a hundred
percent of the member benefits but you
say forty percent so we'll continue
doing a live shout outs and on that note
also a big thank you to Charles Clark
Charles Clark signing up just now at
david pakman.com slash membership not
using the coupon code I voted seventeen
but could hep could have used it and
that would have saved you 40 percent
okay let's get into policy ideas Donald
Trump during this first presidential
address using all sorts of combinations
of distraction ranging from distraction
to miss statements to straight-up lies
okay in discussing his policy ideas
let's go through some of the ideas that
Donald Trump presented tonight Donald
Trump saying that the middle class has
been shrinking okay and that's that's a
that's a problem he wants to address
that as we've exported jobs Trump has
exported jobs Trump's menswear line was
produced in Mexico Trump opted to use
foreign steel and the contraction of
construction of many of his projects so
absolutely hypocritical and not actually
addressing the real issues that are
impacting the inequality that we're
seeing the comparative decline of the
middle class is in great
because people in the lower lower middle
and middle classes are working and their
productivity is being redistributed
something Republicans claim to be
against not down but up through stock
holdings disproportionately by rich
people and executives of big
corporations Trump talking about the
unprecedented rate of drugs entering the
u.s. I'm not sure about that I'm not
sure about that I like to see the data
on that Donald Trump talking about
infrastructure spending now here's where
it got a little interesting Trump
talking about spending a trillion
dollars on infrastructure Republicans
clapped
since when do Republicans like
infrastructure spending now in general I
like infrastructure spending I'm gonna
get to how Trump wants to do it in a
second but how are Republicans cheering
now but when it was Obama trying to do
infrastructure spending when we were in
an absolutely terrible and disastrous
recession Republicans were against it if
you believe conceptually that
infrastructure spending helps the
economy why would you be against it when
President Obama was trying to get us out
of a disastrous recession anyway now
Republicans apparently clapping about
that the way Trump will do it though is
gonna be crony capitalism I've exposed
that before on the show I won't do it
again right now but but I will we will
absolutely talk about that again Trump
wants the drug epidemic to stop yet
we've now learned that the the Justice
Department of Donald Trump is likely
signaling likely that they are going to
be cracking down on marijuana in states
that have legalized and or
decriminalized recreational use
that's the revival of the war on drugs
something we know that is absolutely and
totally failed Trump wants to construct
the wall that was a policy idea that he
talked about we've heard that before
it's stupid it'll build it'll take
longer to build than Trump's first term
even if they started today it will cost
over twenty billion dollars and
obviously most undocumented immigrants
are not physically crossing the border
I'm sorry not most many somewhere
between it might not be most it could be
anywhere from 40 to 60% of undocumented
immigrants
are not even you know there's overstayed
visas they're flying in it's not people
crossing the the us-mexico border Donald
Trump claimed that most attackers most
attackers in the u.s. came from outside
the US since 9/11 that's just totally
untrue I don't know what sort of
semantic game the speech writers had in
their mind when they wrote that for
Trump I don't get how you defend that
most most domestic terrorists in the
United States since 9/11 were born here
in the United States we've talked about
it okay all right a couple thank-yous
Loren Farnsworth thank you for signing
up at david pakman.com slash membership
for a membership using the coupon code I
voted 17 thanks to Joseph Ackerson by
the way we are it's the 28th of the
month if something like nine more people
sign up tonight we will have 500 new
members in February which would not only
be a record for us it would more than
double the previous record and it would
be in the shortest month of the year so
that would be a major accomplishment and
the coupon code I voted 17 will get you
40% off so please do sign up we do a
whole extra show called the bonus show
for our paid subscribers other policy
ideas that we heard from Donald Trump
Donald Trump wants new vetting
procedures we've heard from him what
these procedures are and they're exactly
what the Obama administration did for
eight years I mean just bogus just bogus
unless you are completely lacking
factual information you should not be
tricked by that I mean that the extreme
betting that Trump wants is what Obama
has been doing Trump has talked about
his plan to demolish and destroy Isis I
read a preview of what that plan is
that's been presented it's the plan that
was developed under Barack Obama it's
the plan that was started under Barack
Obama it's laughable that this is
anything unique to the Trump
administration Donald Trump talked about
in terms of context tonight that the US
business tax rate is one of the highest
in the world and Trump wants to lower it
I've said it before I'll say it again
the tax rate on paper is Arella
the tax rate on paper is irrelevant the
question is what is the effective tax
rate that businesses are paying the tax
foundation has made it abundantly clear
that the u.s. effective tax rate is not
actually the highest and we've heard
anecdotally of so many different big
corporations that make billions in
profits and pay no actual taxes tax cuts
don't make you more competitive in an
accounting sense also because if you
investment when III is the president of
the David Pakman show when I make a
decision to invest money back into the
show I buy more equipment or hire
someone or whatever those are tax
deductions I pay zero tax on that and in
fact basic economic thinking would
suggest that if the tax rate is higher
on profits it's an incentive for me to
invest more money in my business if I
take a hundred dollars in profit and I'm
going to pay thirty five percent tax on
that or I could take that hundred
dollars in profit and buy a piece of
equipment to make my show better as soon
as I eliminate that hundred dollars in
profit by buying a hundred dollar camera
I now have reduced my tax because I'm no
longer paying tax on that profit so just
the entire premise of what Trump was
saying was bogus repeal and replace
Obamacare you know Obama care provisions
increasingly popular with Americans
he said the solution is to lower the
cost so that more people can afford it
but at the same time he's saying that he
doesn't want to have an individual
mandate well the the only way that you
can lower the cost is if everyone is
covered because otherwise people who
aren't covered go to the emergency room
which is really expensive and then those
costs which are unlikely to ever be
recovered by hospitals are passed along
premiums go up I mean it's justjust
totally backwards right absolutely and
totally backwards everything that Trump
was saying he wants to support men and
women of law enforcement that's not a
policy proposal that's just more
pandering biggest defense spending
increase in American history Trump
talked about its patriotic is it's
pseudo patriotic I mean it sounds like
it's good for safety we spend an insane
we spend an insane amount on defense we
have 50 bases or something like that in
Germany there's no reason to increase
defense spending period and
controversially to some degree Donald
Trump saying that he supports NATO
they're controversially because there
were doubts about that and this this was
sort of an issue of contention
and and so at sort of near the end of
the speech Trump dropping that in there
that he values NATO okay so those are
some of the policy ideas that Trump
proposed tonight next I am going to get
to the claims that Trump took credit for
and it's rich it is rich you're not
going to want to miss that before I do
that we have a $20 super chap from
Chicago is my city saying do you think
Trump will be a worse president than
george w bush do you find it potentially
dangerous
when we forget the terrible things other
politicians have done and move the more
will go goalposts because of trump yeah
you know I made clear today when I
talked about how George W Bush on The
Today Show yesterday said that we need
to find out that number one media is
indispensable and number two that we
need to figure out what went on with
Trump and Russia I made it clear like
yeah I can agree with Bush on this but
let's not forget that this was an
absolutely disastrous president arguable
war criminal etc etc so I think it's
important not to allow the goalposts to
be moved
also to $2 Super chats from Kingsley de
Jenga
who says your stream won't get as many
views as Alex Jones's if that was worth
$4 to you have at it buddy absolutely
have at it a bunch of new members
signing up over the last few minutes
let's see we have Cassandra costly
Matthew bond gracel Paola grant angle
Brett Katie Ziegler Michael crook and
Lyle frappe ea frappe e'er frappe EA I
don't know how Kyle
Lyle pronounces his last name but thank
you to all the $6 membership costs only
three dollars and 60 cents per month
when you use the coupon code I voted 17
the $60 yearly membership costs only $36
when you use the 40% off coupon code I
voted 17 and that's that's the number
one funding source for the show so I I
do encourage you to become a member we
do extra program
just for our members instead of just
getting the three to five-minute clips
you get a full hour show without the
commercials every single day instead of
having to wait we release the clips
every 90 minutes so it's all it's all
very good okay one interesting comment
and I'm gonna get back to the speech
someone said that I'm a Democrat because
I'm gay I'm actually neither gay nor a
Democrat it's interesting how someone
could be just so wrong so wrong it's
very very interesting okay this is this
is from this for me was like the most
entertaining part of Donald Trump's
abortive presidential address tonight
the accomplishments that Trump took
credit for as you might suggest many of
them were not accomplishments and the
ones that were arguably accomplishments
but very often had nothing to do with
Trump okay so let's dig into it Donald
Trump started with his big claim to fame
companies have announced and he named
carrier and Ford among others companies
have announced that they're gonna invest
billions in the US including carrier and
Ford
most of the companies he name it's bogus
it in the sense that it's not policy
it's not an accomplishment if I have in
my country a bad economic situation and
I find out a company's about to leave
and I go to them and I say take money
take money which is what Trump did with
carrier that's not economic policy
that's not really an accomplishment I
paid someone to stay right and you can't
do that with every company you just
can't so absolutely bogus non
accomplishment stock market gains Donald
Trump took credit for the stock market
gains that we've seen since November 8th
since November 8th okay I will remind
you that President Obama was president
until January 20th and there is no
particular reason to attribute the stock
market change from November 8th to
January 20th to incoming president then
president-elect Donald Trump rather than
President Obama so yes we've seen stock
market gains since January 20th I
believe that that is absolutely
something that can be
used to evaluate a president's total
performance I've made it clear that I'm
invested in the stock market to some
degree I am NOT someone who picks stocks
I've talked a little bit about the
individual stocks I own but it's like
four or five stocks
basically I just invest in index funds
and I'm on the Warren Buffett sort of
mindset of over a lot over the long term
you're very likely to do better with
low-cost index funds so yeah Trump can
take credit for the stock market gains
since January 20th but to take credit
for the gains since November 8th seems
absolutely bogus Donald Trump touted as
an accomplishment his hiring freeze on
federal workers this costs more money
okay
the hiring freeze on federal workers is
the epitome the epitome of the pander
policy that is the opposite of what it
claims to be Trump wants to be fiscally
conservative so he says we're not going
to hire any more federal workers the
problem is if there's work to be done
the works going to need to be done by
someone if you start paying overtime to
the people that are already employed
that's more expensive than having
someone working in their normal 40-hour
a week and in addition to that you often
have to bring in consultants and on a
per hour basis if you've ever dealt with
consultants or are a consultant or
whatever you know that on an hourly
basis consultants charge way more for
the work that they do than somebody who
is employed as a w-2 employee of a
corporation so Trump touting the hiring
freeze really nothing to brag about I
wouldn't be bragging about that okay
draining the swamp Trump took credit for
a completely untrue yeah I'm pretty sure
I heard some boos during that Trump has
filled the swamp more than any recent
president that I can remember everything
from establishment consultants to Wall
Street bankers that he slammed Hillary
Clinton for being associated with during
the campaign absolute totally bogus
accomplishment claimed Trump said that
for each new regulation to must be
eliminated that's just stupid I mean
that that's just that has no objective
connection to an actual evaluation of
what it is that is being proposed or
done Donald Trump said he's going to
stop
regulations that threaten the jobs of
coal miners is anyone else embarrassed
by this because the rest of the world is
laughing at us the world is laughing at
us that as China and India and Brazil
and so many countries Germany with solar
are making progress on renewable and
alternative energy we have a president
here who's going around the country this
isn't just something he keeps quiet and
says to Melania at night he's publicly
saying he's trying to revitalize the
coal industry an industry that is dying
I just read yesterday that there are
more new solar jobs now than coal jobs
in the United States obviously and
Donald Trump is talking about saving an
industry that is destructive to the
environment and is just being laughed at
around the world again not an
accomplishment Donald Trump touted as an
accomplishment that he signed orders to
move forward on the Dakota access
pipeline and Keystone XL that is not an
accomplishment yes it is relevant if the
President of the United States says he
wants to build those pipelines again
which other countries are laughing at us
about about but it's not an
accomplishment it's just a
recommendation he wants that to happen
it's not really something that I would
call doing something Trump also saying
that the pipelines must be made with
American steel that's just funny because
Trump built many of his own buildings
with foreign steel I mean an absolute
and total ludicrous hypocrite laughable
and then I was waiting for it I don't
know who else was waiting for the TPP
thing but Trump talked about major
accomplishment he put an end to TPP TPP
has been dead for months by November
15th I believe it was we had Chuck
Schumer and Mitch McConnell saying it's
not gonna happen
Democrats and Republicans saying it's
not gonna happen and again Donald Trump
taking credit for something that was
dead two months more than two full
months before he became president of the
United States
Trump starting a task force on reducing
violent crime the analyses I've read
suggest that that's again not really an
accomplishment it's a recommendation and
we'll see what happens
he wants to core
a strategy to dismantle drug cartels
legalize marijuana decriminalize
marijuana that has been analyzed time
and again and it has been determined to
be something that would do so much to
hurt those drug cartels but we've got
Jeff Sessions who used to like the KKK
until he found out that they smoked pot
hinting hinting that we are going to get
more cracking down on marijuana
including in states that have legalized
decriminalized already okay and a couple
more things Trump says he wants to
enforce an immigration laws which is
code for you know to deport people he
says that he wants to help unemployed
people he wants to raise wages and he
wants to make communities safer in that
context those are all illusions to
immigrants Hispanic immigrants take our
jobs Hispanic immigrants keep wages down
and Hispanic immigrants commit crime and
we've very specifically debunked just
about all those claims I encourage you
to check out our video on YouTube called
the truth about dangerous job stealing
immigrants okay check that out and then
see if you can make heads or tails out
of what Trump's talking about and then
lastly as an accomplishment Trump said
that he kept his promise to a point of
justice from the list of 20 that some
right-wing think-tank gave him I
wouldn't be bragging about the fact that
you're doing what random think tanks
that you talked to before you're elected
told you to do okay I would try to avoid
talking about that but Trump talking
about it as an accomplishment
embarrassing okay let's look at what's
happening in the super chat amber wetter
Zack says for the $5 super chat what was
your thought on Kelly Conway is
inappropriate manner sitting on the
couch in the Oval Office pictures today
yeah I saw the pictures of Kellyanne
Conway who basically if you've noticed
since she made up the Bowling Green
massacre which didn't happen
she has basically disappeared from
interviews and yeah she was spotted in
the Oval Office today when Trump was
meeting with the presidents and
officials from historically black
colleges and universities with her heels
dug into the couch it was weird it
seemed inappropriate to me just if
you're talking about respecting the
office of the president you'd think you
wouldn't just be hanging out there
sitting on the couch like a
three-year-old it was odd but altogether
not not the biggest story a $20 super
chat from Chris Becca Levski Becca loose
key Becca let's see not sure how Chris
pronounces his or her last name
many women named Chris could be
Christina could be Christine $5.00 super
chat from 280z turbo are liberals at an
inherent political disadvantage compared
to trump isnora independently and are
less likely to fall in line I don't know
that that's the issue I think that
liberals are if there's an inherent
disadvantage to liberalism it is that
the policies are more nuanced so if I go
on the radio and this is part of why in
fact I'm reading I don't have it here
waves of rancor which is a really good
book about right-wing media if I go on
the radio go hey taxes are bad it's my
money
government's taking it from me tax
relief relieve me by taking taxes away
it's pretty simple right you're gonna
get a lot of people behind that the
liberal position is not more taxes the
better get as many taxes as possible
that's what we want know that the the
answer would be well government needs to
balance revenue with allowing people to
retain the money that they did earn and
we have to evaluate what aspects of
daily life whether it's roads or schools
or whatever should be funded by tax
money in order to have strong commons in
a society that's rummaging you've
already put yourself at a disadvantage
so I think that the inherent faux
simplicity of right-wing positions is
what can put progressives at a
disadvantage okay MS PowerPoint has sent
oh this is that this is that I think
someone last time said it's Indian
rupees although I don't know for sure a
2
100 some currency statement saying I
found the speech pretty presidential he
condemned condemned hate threats and
shootings if you were not affiliated
with the progressive movement would you
still have criticized him I mean hope
would I I don't even know how to answer
that how if if I were Bill O'Reilly I
probably would not be criticizing these
the this speech right that would be my
guess I don't really know how I can
answer that I'm calling it as I see it
I'm not putting forth some kind of phone
neutrality
I am a progressive and I'm giving you
the analysis as I see it okay thank you
to the people that are signing up we
have a number of new members including I
want to make sure I don't skip over
anybody here Mary Sherman Johnny or
Jamie bacon Lauren Farnsworth has picked
up some David Pakman show coffee at
david pakman.com slash gear Victor
Martinez is now a member Barbara Beach
moody is now a member Chris Vica left
speed the cholesky again Chris who sent
the super chat signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership and Tory
powers signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership we've had a record
month folks we've had a record month of
new subscribers we've had a I believe
February which is usually one of the
worst months of the year in the sense
that it's a 28 day month every once in a
while it's a 29 day month it's usually a
pretty bad month on YouTube it's
actually on track to be a record month
as well so I really just can't thank
everybody enough including everybody who
even as I'm talking is signing up here
at david pakman.com slash membership and
really if the normal rates of 6 bucks a
month or 60 for the year are too high
take the 40% discount
I voted 17 and let's do it I mean I I
see no reason no reason to get people to
pay full price if they'd rather pay less
and you still get a hundred percent of
the benefits
okay anybody that should get blocked in
the chat I mean there's always out of
the corner of my eye I always see [ __ ]
Jew Jew [ __ ] often is a popular one with
with some of the trolls so I don't know
if there's anybody here that that should
be banned I'm not know but nobody's
paying particular attention I mean
nobody's particularly getting my
attention and that's usually a sign that
someone needs to be banned I guess we'll
just let it run for now okay what else
is on tomorrow's show and we're not
going to be able to go to too long with
this because I do have to go to bed and
we do have a program tomorrow to do
hatred mail tomorrow is Wednesday so we
are going to be doing hate mail that the
hatred mail is absolutely stunning what
we have for you tomorrow
we also tomorrow are going to be talking
about well I don't actually know which
of these stories will make it tomorrow
but I'm looking at a story about the
Peruvian president recently making some
comments about Donald Trump saying he
prefers bridges to walls but we actually
found out that the Peruvian president
has built some walls himself Oh gays are
not not completely innocent we have the
results from the David Pakman show
audience survey we may get to that
tomorrow that's not super time-sensitive
so we may have to push that off I am
looking at a story tomorrow about 229
House Republicans voting to keep Donald
Trump's tax returns secret hmm why would
they want to do that we may look at that
tomorrow we have had suspicious deaths
suspicious deaths of six Russian
diplomats in just four months it's
triggering conspiracy theories it's also
triggering pretty reasonable non
conspiratorial questions about what the
hell is going on
and we also have a leaked report about
what we believe will be put forward
maybe in terms of an Obamacare
replacement proposal from Republicans
it's just as bad as what we guessed okay
just as bad as what we guessed we have a
ten Canadian dollar super chat from Sean
Stanhope David
so you think Bernie Sanders could put
his health care plan up his replacement
to the affor
we'll Care Act pitch it on TV and
Congress sure Bernie can do it
Bernie can do it but we've seen also
even just within the DNC when we look
when we saw the DNC election results Tom
Perez defeating keith ellison that was
in a way a rejection of the Bernie wing
of the Democratic Party so yeah I mean
Medicare for all I think is a absolutely
great idea
I don't know that Bernie Sanders is
going to be welcomed with completely
open arms from Republicans or Democrats
at this point so I don't know
strategically if that's going to happen
I'm noticing that my entire microphone
is kind of curved here or twisted and
that that's bothering people
I apologize let's see if I can get this
thing untwisted I probably should not
store it rolled up that would really be
I think the way to prevent this from
happening okay thanks to Seth varam who
has just ordered a bag of david pakman
show coffee roasted locally here 40 40
35 40 minutes away at blue Bluefire
Coffee Roasters by Patrick Maloney you
can get your coffee at david pakman.com
slash gear i'm thinking of doing a live
stream from blue fire coffee roasters
where I will go and roast coffee with
Patrick and then help bag the coffee to
send out to david pakman show viewers
you don't actually have to wear any
special clothing to go and roast the
coffee but I feel like visually it would
be funnier if I wore like a hazmat suit
or a beekeepers outfit during the
livestream when I'm roasting the coffee
even though obviously it's not it's not
necessary to roast coffee I think we
know that also big thank you to
Elizabeth Altman and Albert Villegas
both of whom just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership albert
opting to use the 40% discount code
which is I voted 17 Elizabeth opting not
only to not use the 40% discount code
but actually signing up for a level 2
membership the base prices are 6 bucks a
month $60 for the year although by all
means if you want to support us at a
higher
you absolutely can okay so that is
something that is available also on
tomorrow's show
stories I'm looking at I'm considering
this story about Betsy DeVos Trump's
education secretary put out a press
release that seems to basically
celebrate Jim Crow education systems as
school choice and it really just
confirms the idea that that well
obviously that she's the exact opposite
of what you would want in an education
secretary but also that school choice is
code for really bad things when
Republicans say it and I mentioned this
in my analysis of the Trump speech but
we do now have a story what is the
source let me just look at it here I've
got a story from I'm not able to find it
Oh
CIA dot-gov what is C I a gov the US
Energy Information Administration about
how solar is now providing twice as many
jobs as the coal industry and this
directly relates to a lot of the stuff
that Donald Trump was talking about
during his speech today and then here's
something I don't know if people would
be interested in me covering this I did
a story years ago years ago that went
viral and it was about a black woman who
submitted identical resumes one with her
real name which is sort of a
stereotypically stereotypically black
sounding name and then resubmitted the
exact same resume to all of the same
employers potential employers with a
less traditionally black sound your
stereotypical black sounding name and
the number of interview requests
exploded there is a study which points
to and this is from NPR that Asian last
names also lead to fewer job interviews
okay and I'm looking at maybe doing that
story I think it would be of interest to
the audience although it's hard to fit
in some of these more generally
interesting stories when we have insane
[ __ ] happening at 3:00 a.m. just about
every day so we'll see if we get to that
if not I maybe I should do a
a weekend stream where I can just catch
up on the stories we weren't able to to
get too big thank you - I know I'm gonna
screw this up big THANK YOU to kuru
Cameron I think that's the way kuru is
pronounced and caster this is just a
very difficult polish last name let's
see if I can if I can do this
zu with schinsky am i close they're
castor casters of izinski who signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership and
also nicole gates nicole gates thank you
for signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership as well as lisa house Ehrman
lisa house Ehrman this entire stream
will be on the channel later other than
election night this is my record I think
we hit a peak of did anybody see was it
like 1,300 people on the stream I think
it was roughly something like that okay
a lot of people seem upset with me in
the chat some people upset that I'm
Jewish some people upset that others are
making fun of me because I'm Jewish
people discussing my sexual orientation
which happens to be heterosexual yeah a
lot a lot of stuff happening in the chat
there so on that note it's getting late
I'm going to bed thanks to everybody for
joining me please do sign up we're
funded by membership if you guys want
the show to continue three hundred and
thirty thousand subscribers strong
nearly on YouTube thanks to you on track
I should mention on track to hit 500
thousand YouTube subscribers I believe
based on the numbers we ran somewhere
around November somewhere around
November let me double check that
actually and these these projections
change all the time right but actually
no it's moved up a little bit so in in
mid-august we are projected to hit
500,000 subscribers but this can change
this is because things have been really
they've been big-league lately
that you never know when big league will
continue Jeff Chia Jeff Chia thank you
for signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership keep the signups coming it
would be great to start off March 1st
strongly we'll talk to you tomorrow